and I guess that's really the point you
learn you think you approach you begin
to do an audience tells you where you're
going back that's right we're going is
wrong but the creativity never thought
so I need to teach them what they can
learn about jazz and for me it's key
it's the jazz aesthetic because we all
have the ability to improvise we all are
creative we don't have to unlock it it's
there when we're born
see a crazy
this event we're at right now this
Leadership Conference it happens each
year does bring together so many
different people who are contributing
and it gives us a chance to bump up
against each other and talk about things
and share ideas I really look forward
this every year participating at this
leaders assembly is so enriching
literally the conversation that I had
with with the president of the club in
London and we participate on conference
calls for our subgroup that we work on
and then for the first time I met a
face-to-face here so there is that
dialogue that you wouldn't have
otherwise but it's just as important to
have this annual gathering so I can put
a person with the profile picture
so every year we honor Ten alumni who
have dedicated over ten years of service
to either their school or to the
University overall and this gala tonight
honors them
the CAA is a tapestry the CIA is
community CAA is an extended family the
CAA is empowering the CAA is you
you